hi Luca hi Steve how you doing not too
bad you know it's a real pleasure for me
by the way I should say that I'm talking
to Luke lumpar yellow who and where are
you right now by the way I'm in Paris or
you're in Paris okay I'm Steve Kaufman
and I have enjoyed watching Lukas videos
I'm very impressed with all of his
languages particularly you know Chinese
and Russian and German I mean it's one
thing to be fluent everybody speaks
English and it's one thing as an Italian
to speak Spanish in Portuguese in French
but once you wander off into the more
exotic languages I'm very impressed
thank you thank you very much so what I
thought we'd do is maybe talk a little
bit about our one of our favorite
subjects which is language learning and
we can do it first in English and then
we have an order of languages here we're
gonna go French Spanish German Italian
Swedish Russian and Chinese and we'll
see how fine I get as we get to the
bottom of the list both you and I
struggle a little bit more okay first of
all question I often get asked is why
this interest in learning so many
languages well I gotta tell you truth
it's an interested I I really know it is
something that I discovered when I was
13 around 12 13 maybe it comes from my
aunt my aunt has always been passionate
about languages in general and I had
been hearing so much you know how old
speaking languages is great and my aunt
actually speaks a five or even six I
think so that kind of maybe was within
my family and I don't know 12 she gave
me a book analyst book and I decided to
I just start reading it and that's
basically your family was you were
brought up in a unilingual Italian
speaking environment yeah 100%
unilingual environment absolutely so
when you started reading a book in
English I mean how did you manage that
it's just based on your school English
um yes that's it I am learning English
for a couple years actually I started
learning English at the age of 10 that's
cool but I Cyril
I seriously starting glitch learning
English at the age of 13 means that I
started learning by myself plus I had a
private teacher but until the age of 13
my English was kind of disastrous since
they you know you mentioned you started
reading like as you know having seen
some of my videos I think reading is a
tremendously powerful way of increasing
one's familiarity with with the language
acquiring vocabulary and I and I think
that they there's far too little sort of
reading in school and far too much
teaching have you got any comment on
that I agree 100 percent the proper the
problem the main problem is for example
there's a lot of people ask me how can
you speak English so well and the answer
is that I've been reading tons of books
and this goes for every language the
ability you know I don't think that I
think that reading makes people more
intelligent it means that people are
inside they have their own intelligence
but the reading gives you the
possibility of connecting the dots you
know absolutely I mean it enables you to
reach out to worlds that are far removed
from where you are in time and space
other people's thoughts and you want to
tremendous medium if someone if we only
had mp3 players and didn't have books
would be a lot poorer oh yeah definitely
yeah that's that's why I always say I
just wanted to make a video on this a
reading changes everything
yeah reading but we're not just talking
about language learning reading is in
general you know and and I think people
wait too long they get on to language
learning they're trying to nail down the
imperfect you know the identity of case
or whatever they should just be reading
and and they continue with very
primitive childish not very credible
learner content instead of making that
jump into reading something real you
know the thing is that for example I
always give advice on starting to learn
a language with a book like a Simone or
teach yourself or whatever they're
learning you really start learning
language for real when you hit the real
content you know things like books or
instant content something which is
interesting to you that
the key point and what I do for example
is that I don't I just say my technique
is a technique to start learning a
language but the real learning happens a
little bit later no for for example when
I'm able to enjoy a book okay that a
huge difference I agree with you so that
the teacher self-esteem know whatever it
is is just that first ladder to get you
up to the basically the escalator once
you're not the escalator you're gonna
and it's a long long sort of road but if
you keep reading and listening to the
real language intended for the speakers
of that language you can you cannot but
improve you have to improve exactly and
one more thing is that once you are on
that ladder things get slightly easier
because you know the mechanisms of the
language are ingrained in you have
understood by reading and listening
reading and listening you have the
possibility of understanding more and
then when you find yourself at the top
of the of the mountain because they
think I personally think that the first
month six months depending on the
language not if it's Chinese or Japanese
are the most delicate most difficult
because it's it's a steep slow slowly
absolutely it's this yes you're still
struggling with the strangeness whereas
if you go to a related language it's not
quite so strange you just have to learn
some of the different vocabulary
different structures different phrase
patterns but it's not so tremendously
strange yeah another thing we will stay
in English maybe for a couple of more
minutes here then we'll move on to
related language which French is in a
way so vocabulary now people say well
how can you read if you don't know the
language so there's this other area
where I disagree with some people a lot
of people say well you have to read
books that are 95 percent words that you
know it's this grade and reader you know
the n plus one and so forth and I have
never followed that approach because I
find the graded readers so uninteresting
so I find that if I'm interested in the
subject I would rather struggle with
texts that have a higher percentage of
unknown words how do you deal with that
oh well what I do is something
progressive I think there's a theory to
remember exactly whose theory but
he said that you always have to choose a
slightly the test texts which are
slightly more difficult than your level
so that you can because if you choose
texts which are too easy you don't learn
anything so I what I try to do is
actually always try it well especially
what what I do is to find texts that
have audio that's the first thing that I
did agree yeah and because my technique
is reading and listening at the same
time you know there's sub recently I got
a couple of questions some I've long a
person asked me are you more auditory I
don't remember exactly what he said but
he wanted an art by a [ __ ] this style
learning style wanted to learn and I
tweeze you're a learner or as an aural
learner
yeah or visually I told them I think I
personally think we are all bet we all
have eyes and ears I agree with you a
hundred percent if we can use both of
these things it's pretty powerful you
know always so what I constantly do is
to find texts which are slightly more
difficult than my my my level my current
level where there's a lot of words a lot
of words it's some words that I don't
know and I try to listen and read as
much as I can first step then there's
step two that's different it's another
story this is what I do with text
support what you're saying and some
people may prefer reading some people
may prefer listening some people may in
fact remember things better when they
read or when they listen but I agree
with you we both benefit from having
both and I I at one point said you
should never as a learner attack any
text that doesn't have audio and you
should not listen to audio that doesn't
have text now I've backed off that
because it's just not practical I'm in
check right now and I do a lot of
reading without audio and I have some
sources that are pure audio and and I
have no choice but in an ideal scenario
I agree with you you should have both
well I think it's very important
especially when you're learning a
language when still in the stage that
you're learning a language and later
when you're an advanced stage so to say
you can read a book you can listen to it
you can watch a movie you're listening
to whatever you want to listen ready for
example but at the beginning what he'll
stage 1 and stage 2 where you're
deliberately learning a language it is
pretty important to have text and audio
at least as far as I'm concerned well
then there's people who actually say
well you know I like the Mitchell Thomas
method where they just teach you the
language by talking they're just and I
want to read but I think that it as
adults we can use actually our eyes and
our ears in our capacity we have an
incredible advantage which is the
ability to read reading is very powerful
I have never I bought Mike Michel Thomas
I've bought most systems and people have
different preferences and some people
like Michel Thomas I couldn't listen to
him I couldn't listen to these people
stumbling in the language that they were
learning I couldn't listen to it I can
tell the truth as far as I'm concerned
I've been hearing a lot about
Pimsleur and Mitchell Thomas being very
effective but I've never tried it it's
I'm not this is not my style you know I
don't like being prompted I'm not in a
hurry to speak I want to understand
before I speak so I don't need to be
prompted you know what did so-and-so do
in English asking me you know no I don't
need that so you were said you had a
point one then you had a point two you
were gonna come - yeah what point one is
that I think that the main goal is to
understand what you're learning that's
very important so I always have an audio
audio and then I have a text but I also
try to activate what I'm doing at what
I'm learning this doesn't necessarily
mean that I speech but in today you know
it's called there there's some mechanism
which is called mirror neurons what I do
is for example I have a text I analyze
it analyzes just normal reading and
listening that is understanding a text
by you know using bilingual know they
have a translation but a and then I just
what I do is in order to remember things
to remember words which are the breaks
that gotta make the wall what I do is
that I translate it back but a few days
later it means that for example I
consider a text in the language L - I
call it the language learning and then I
use the normal things which is you know
listening and reading many times you
know in a language no rote memorization
and and then what I do is that a few
days later
once I was seeing and listened to the
stacks numerous times I translated back
into my native trunk but why do first
this and I first tried it in my my own
my own native you know Italian and then
I translate back but by translating back
I don't I use ideas
it is very importantly because people
some people said yeah but if you do this
translation thing then you run the risk
of getting stuck with your native tongue
and then you're constantly thinking in
what terms of your native tongue but
what I do is a special technique I'm not
gonna reveal everything now but what I
do is you know enables me to remember
words in context above all the sentences
and then and remember the words right
okay I mean of course you're a
translator - a professional translator
and interpreter I think no no I'm not a
professional and no I'm attending a
school that's for interpreting and
conference interpreting but not just for
learning languages that's a tool okay
now again I think we all have our
preferred ways of doing things and I
must admit that since I'm more of a
hobby learner I avoid doing things that
are hard work so for me I mean one of
the things that I I agree with you with
this mirror-neuron thing and one of the
things that I do somewhat sporadically
is that I will save phrases at link and
I'll use the Google Translate
translation just because I can't create
the the link card without having
something in the translation space and
very often the the Google Translate is
wrong I know the meaning of the phrase I
just can't produce it very well so then
I go back in and I'll fix up the the
Google translation so that's already I'm
spending time with that phrase and you
know every time you spend some time with
something it's helping you learn it so I
fixed it up so now I've got a hundred
phrases where the the English makes
sense where in a sense I've translated
from say Czech to English now I go
through the flashcards I do them in
Reverse so I'm looking at my translation
of the English
and I have to then translate this into
check and then I flipped the flashcard
and I see the translation I can also go
then to the dictation feature in our
vocab section and I can read this the
phrase again and I can then you know try
to say the phrase then I hear the
text-to-speech okay and text-to-speech
is fine for that purpose I mean I
couldn't listen to a whole book in
text-to-speech but when you're dealing
with short phrases text the speeches is
quite good enough so yeah I do these
things but I end up doing them
sporadically for the simple reason that
if you ask me if I would rather move on
to the next chapter in the good soldier
shake or listen to radio Prague or do
this exercise I just described to you
I'd rather move ahead in my reading so
the problem is that I just can't force
myself I don't have the discipline given
the amount of time that I have available
for learning I end up doing the things
that I find more fun you know so it's
not that doing that is not a good thing
it's just that you know you've got to be
pretty discipline to force yourself to
do it yeah - yeah that's true but as far
as the languages are in since I love it
so much it's a pleasure the other thing
is that translating back and forth might
be a little bit heavy for some people
and i perfectly agree there are my
people who might say oh but i don't want
to do this this is kind of a hard work
it's true but at the same time i I like
you very much I'm talking about me of
course absolutely and I think we have to
say right up front that that language
learning if you aren't enjoying it
you're gonna learn so people yeah if you
like what you're you have to like you
love what you do exactly that you like
doing one last thing before we finish
and what I think we might do is well
we'll terminate our English discussion
and then we'll start a separate multi
language discussion otherwise each
recording is gonna be too long but one
final point and that is when we sort of
touched on it here this is this sort of
dilemma like I I feel that personally I
don't like to get into a situation where
I have to talk to someone and I don't
understand what they're saying and I
struggle to put even elementary thoughts
together so my process typically is to
focus on understanding building up my
vocabulary and
and since I'm not in the situation where
I need to speak the language like a
learning check here in Vancouver it's it
suits my purpose I listen I read I enjoy
I learned a ton about Czech history
modern politics and stuff like that
and I figured one day I'll I'll be able
to start speaking I'm under no pressure
to do so on the other hand what you say
is true that if there's some things that
you can start like I forced myself to
talk with a tutor because I know it it
does help me even though it's something
that I don't like to do so how do you
sort of this issue of understanding
versus output and how much output and
when and how do you where do you come on
come out on this subject well as far as
speaking okay first the most important
thing for me is to listen and read and
apply my technique and getting inputs
because I think that input is absolutely
the most essential thing that you have
to do but as far as you know people
think that I start speaking from day one
which is something I had never done any
language I probably start speaking six
months later yes yeah start learning the
language but but the thing is that
speaking is a little bit vague is a
little bit general you can speak to a
native speaker you can talk to yourself
some people think it's not very useful
what I do is after three or four months
and start talking to myself small chunks
small sentences it's adjust the
pronunciation etc so I'm not stressed
because actually it's something talking
to a native speaker it's a stressful
event probably the problems when you're
when you're looking at the person your
brain is looking at the person having to
has to do multitasking you know it
cannot do it asked it yet when you speak
the language it is something that has
become automatic and the problem is when
you're still there is still a beginner
in the language I don't think it's very
useful to talk to people immediately you
know there's some people over the
Internet in general you know start
speaking from day one I think that you
know if you have the if you like doing
that if you have the personality but I
don't think that that it applies to the
majority of people were going to
have a lot of problems that kind of
approach that's funny and I think one of
the flaws in traditional language
teaching is that the emphasis the
emphasis seems to be on getting you to
speak right away getting you to produce
something the teacher says I taught you
this now produce it and then yes that's
what generates the kind of resistance
because if you try to impose something
on somebody they were going to say no I
want to think that is an oh you calls me
a lawyer you pose me this I don't want
to do it and that's guess the the
opposite reaction you know I agree with
you on talking to yourself and or any of
these techniques and I know you have a
number of techniques to get you to start
priming the pump so to speak just to
start getting the brain working a little
bit so that when you do have to confront
the native speaker you're at least able
to hold up your end sometimes well what
I think is that if you do something
progressive for example you start
talking to yourself yeah of course
there is nobody correcting your
pronunciation but you can record cells
you can alter yourself and those are the
births recordings are going to stay
there and you can possible you can take
a look if you listen again but it's
already a start you know you have to
start somewhere because you never speak
you will never speak that's never gonna
happen the way as far as I'm concerned I
do it progressively it meets I first at
first you know yet input in me then
after three or four months I start
speaking a little bit to myself then a
chanting I start activating the
languages progressively and then after
six nine months I have enough words
because you could only have words you
cannot speech that's a bit you know I
have a lot of words so when I have got
some words and I know some basic
structures I start being simple
sentences and then I move on to real
conversations okay well listen why don't
we stop it there and I will we'll have
another discussion then in French but
thank you very much and yeah I was
hoping we'd have a big argument about
something but basically we agree because
it is good that people disagree because
because people it's I think we both
agree that people have to enjoy the
process and you will have preferences
for doing certain things over other
things so that there are gonna be
differences in approach based on what
people like doing that's
inevitable that's true okay thank you
see you later